hello everybody welcome back to
murder mystery mood this is the
fourth time that we've done it i've lost
count i don't know but we're trying to
do them once a month so if you're into
these come back every month we'll have
one for you
i wanted to start off with our sponsor
zola so if you are
in the mood to get hitched like if you
just said the mood strikes you today
if you were supposed to get married and
then um some
events happened in 2020 and postponed
your wedding um
perhaps you're on your way to planning
again you're like where do i start i
don't even know how to start anymore
well um zola makes it easy for you it
makes it easy to find wedding vendors in
your area
explore save the dates and invitations
create a free wedding website very
important
build your registry it's basically it's
a wedding planner
without you having to pay thousands of
dollars wedding planner prices
exactly so get on zola if you're a
bride-to-be or a groom to be
or grooms can plan weddings too yeah
exactly
or a mother of the bro you know whoever
you are you need help planning a wedding
this is for you go to zolo.com big mood
today and use promo code
save 50 that's save 5-0 to get your 50
off your to get 50
off your save the dates you also get
free personalized paper samples for your
purchase
that's zola.com big mood promo code
save 50. and we like to start off with a
drink so i picked a grasshopper for you
guys
today it's the month of march i feel
like green drinks should be
in even though this might be after st
patrick's day i don't know
i don't know what timeline you're living
in but
i try to make it simple for you so this
is a three ingredient drink
we got creme de cacao we got
creme de menthe a lot of cremes
happening here and we got
some whole milk or cream or i like to
use cashew milk but don't tell jess
because she doesn't like vegan
this one actually covered up the flavor
of the weird vegan milk so i'm enjoying
it i like it weird
vegan [ __ ] weird vegan fake ass milk
with no titties anyway
you're gonna shake it in a shaker with
ice we got um
0.75 ounces of both the creme de menthe
and the creme de cacao and then
like 1.5 ounces of the cream that you're
using
shake it with ice and a shaker and
strain into a martini glass or
if you're if you want to be trashy you
could just put it in a glass like this
and put some ice in there and
whatever it tastes the same it tastes
like what did you call it an annie's
mint yeah you guys know those
chocolates if you like pepper like kind
of like a minty peppermint tea some
people are like uh toothpaste thin mint
but for me i like it kind of seems like
a chocolatey mint chocolate
yeah yeah it's good if you like that i
don't
know
if you don't like thin mint girl scout
cookies yeah i don't know i don't like
mint flavor right and also well this is
a very minimal
just i just i stopped drinking alcohol
but i can taste
pregnant i'm not pregnant i'm trying to
get pregnant i'm just trying
to baby wants it baby wants it
oh it does taste like that chocolate
andy's chocolate
yeah which i love those i could eat it i
could eat 15 of them just like it right
it's good pretty cool very cooling thank
you for this i like this better than the
white russian cheers thank you
cheers cheers i'm already feeling a
little tipsy
hell yeah i'm a little bit drunk already
let's take a date
all right let's talk something about the
whole thing almost murder
i am faded let's go welcome back to
another episode of murder mystery mood
i will be leading today's episode and uh
today we have me gina me tiff
it's jessica it's nikki
couch so the
murder mystery that i chose today um i
chose this because it's one of my
favorite ones and also
i've been to the murder location site
before oh okay
gina flex on us okay murder tour
been to this murder house yep yeah
that's crazy
[Laughter]
okay okay so today's episode
is about the case of gypsy rose
blanchard
oh i feel like i've heard that name
before but i don't remember what it is
so thank you
yeah so this mystery this case
was so popular that it also has a
netflix
series on it oh it does oh i just
watched the other one because we did the
seasonal hotel yeah this is yeah
um so i'm glad everyone says it
differently
i think it's cecil i don't know cecil
cecil you know um so
that's very exciting to me that there's
also a netflix special on this one thank
you because now i get to go home and
binge that
ye so this is a story about
a girl named gypsy rose he's lucky just
kidding sorry
britney spears reference all right this
is the case of gypsy rose blanchard and
her mom dede
this is a story of a very sweet mother
and daughter a very devoted mother named
dede
who took care of her daughter because
her daughter
was constantly sick ever since she was
about
three months old she was in and out of
the hospital first starting with sleep
apnea
and oh that young yeah crazy yeah
they've been
in and out of the hospital since she was
a little baby
and it turns out she had leukemia
she had muscular dystrophies this is the
daughter right yeah the daughter
yeah and so this was like a devoted
mother she
was a single mother because she got
married young and the husband
left they got a divorce and she decided
to take the daughter and move in with
her parents
why'd they get divorced that
[ __ ] left her with her baby okay
i'm gonna stop
they basically got divorced because he
yeah he basically felt that he got
married for all the wrong reasons
he abandoned his family okay she's angry
on brand let's go so when gypsy was
about eight years old dede described her
as
suffering from leukemia muscular
dystrophy and said she required of
what's this marshalls and by proxy
a wheelchair she needed a wheelchair and
a feeding tube
um it would also include like seizures
asthma and hearing and
visual impairment everything possible
yeah so poor girl you know and then
it was you know their case got picked up
by the media they were always
helped by uh the make-a-wish foundation
they lived where katrina happened and
their house got destroyed
and so because of all her sicknesses you
know gypsy
had so many medications that she had to
take and she had a breathing machine
every night that she had to
use um she went through multiple
surgeries including
optic nerve surgery they took out her
um what is it these salivary glands
nuts my dog had to get her her salivary
glands removed
i didn't know they did that for humans
that's because whenever the doctor saw
her she was constantly drooling because
of all her multiple
illnesses she also had all of her teeth
rotted because of all the medication
that she had to take
this poor baby they had to yank out all
her teeth she was
the small thing five foot tall bald head
thick glasses no teeth at all but she
was a sweet little thing
and her mom was always by her side and
taking such good care of her
um so after hurricane katrina in
2005 she uh their apartment was ruined
um but also they decided to move to
where my parents live now springfield
missouri
wow and the reason why they moved
from louisiana to missouri yeah so far
that's pretty far
so the reason why they moved is because
doctors started getting kind of
suspicious
why don't our tests show these things
that you're saying that your daughter
has
and then whenever the doctor gets
suspicious she would leave that doctor
and go to another one
and then another one and then another
one so eventually it got
a little bit too hot for her and they
moved to missouri and thanks to
habitat for humanity uh they built them
a nice home
with a nice wheelchair ramp and a hot
tub oh and uh
they got everything from free flights to
going to disney world for free like
staying at the mcdonald's
foundation house or whatever and anyone
who saw the mother dede was like she's
such a devoted mother
she's such a good mother she's always
there by her daughter's side
like she's just an angel of a woman well
it turns out
you were right this is munchausen's by
proxy which means
she gypsy was never sick ever
she never had any of these issues but
dede loved the attention
the title of the doting mother like oh
yes yes i am great i am great
look at my daughter like whoa we're on
tv we're getting all these free things
so basically that is what munchausen's
by proxy is
she was acting like her daughter had all
these issues so that she can get all the
love and attention
and so like the drooling thing that
happened it's because
deity would put numbing cream all over
gypsy's mouth
to make her drool she got her daughter's
teeth
[ __ ] yanked out and salivary glands
she lied about everything i just
realized that um like because recently i
was hearing about munch houses
and i guess that's like on its own
that's a thing where like you pretend to
be sick or you make yourself sick all
the time
m m's but then there's also no eminem
had eminem's mom had manchester by proxy
she would always try to make him be sick
yeah she would put
stuff in his food drug him like all
kinds of stuff yeah i've heard of this
so speaking of drugging um the reason
why
dede knows so much about medical things
because she was a nurse
at one point in her life so she was able
to describe things
[ __ ] yeah and also before she left her
parents house
her relatives said that she had a
stealing problem
and she had she always wrote bad checks
and also they think that she murdered
her mother
because or she got her mother sick and
eventually died because
when she was taking care of her mother
she was putting things in her medication
or in her food in her food and then
after she moved the mother was
miraculously okay again no way
yeah like much better so she tested on
her mother first
pretty much yeah and then you know she
was like a doting daughter who took care
of her mother so well
how does she get found out yeah we'll
get to that one okay
okay i'm curious so she would fake all
these she was able to get gypsy
to show all these symptoms like oh she's
so lethargic because you know she would
feed her sleeping meds before
they went to the doctor so she was late
she was you know tired all the time
she told everyone that gypsy was only
like 11 years old 12 years old uh she
told everyone that
gypsy had a functioning or her like she
had the mind of like a seven-year-old
how old was she she was 19 years old oh
my god
yeah i mean she's basically kind of
abusing her and disrupting her growth
from a baby but i mean like yeah
disrupting her ability to grow
too so i mean there probably was a lot
of latency in her mental
growth you know like does that mean that
she just had like zero long-term friends
or like she just didn't talk to her
family at all because they would also
like they would
math it like the [ __ ] she's 19. so how
that worked was
um you know she left with just gypsy and
then
took her out of school as early as
people are saying kindergarten and
to homeschool her so she did learn how
to read and write in homeschool but
basically had no friends no freedom
whatsoever
but she mentally was you know she was
not
slow or anything um but she looked tiny
she was only five feet tall
damn she was always in a wheelchair
nourished too
her head was bald because her mother
shaved her head all the time to get that
look
and then she told gypsy oh yeah you know
the medication you take would have made
you
bald anyway so i'm gonna shave it and
how she got gypsy to
go along with it was basically she did
abuse gypsy she would
uh beat her she would deny her food um
she everywhere they went together she
was always holding gypsy's hand
and every time gypsy talks too much or
says anything she squeezes it really
tight
and that's how gypsy knows not to say
anything
so that's how she controlled her
eventually even when she turned 18
she convinced gypsy to sign over a paper
that basically says i'm not mentally
sound enough to take care of myself
so my mother can take care of me for the
rest of my life like a conservatorship
we all know what that is now so
she uh because dede had convinced her
you know the world is dangerous no one
will ever take care of you like i do
you know and just like you need to sign
this so that i can take care of you for
the rest of your life i am your mother
dearest i'm the only one who will ever
love you like this um
and that's not love that's [ __ ] crazy
that your own mother could do that to
you
yeah and then whenever people ask like
oh where's her father where's her father
the father and his new wife have always
wanted to see gypsy but for some reason
you know dede always comes up with a oh
yeah sorry we can't today we can't today
and she would tell everyone else like
her dad was a drunk he didn't take care
of us he's
you know he does drugs and stuff where
in reality he was actually sending them
uh what is it child support all the time
every month so she was making money off
of that she was making money off
donations
free housing and all that all at the
expense of gypsy
this kind of reminds me of um there's
this do you i mean you guys are the
creators of american horror story
um like ryan murphy and foul check i
forgot the other guy's name but um they
so i think they also created this other
show called the politician and within
that
show is almost like it sounds exactly
like the story but i know those creators
pull from like real life stuff a lot
like they did black dahlia and other
stuff like they
they mix it into their stories so i feel
like i've almost heard this story
through that show if you guys have seen
on netflix the politician it's a pretty
good
show yeah i feel like that's a that's a
side story line yeah in that show i feel
like
no i recently saw a movie i think it was
called run or something where it was
about a girl a teenage girl
that like she's been wheelchair bound
her whole life and then
uh she like at one point like she found
out what kind of medication she was
taking which was
not meant for her like her for humans
and so
she ended up discovering that her mom
was poisoning her actually sarah
paulson's in that
she's the mom which she's also an
american horror story in
sixth sense they have a character that
died from manchester by proxy
i don't even remember that which one the
daughter like the the mom poise
basically
kept the daughter sick and then like i
remember that the daughter ended up
dying
i need to re-watch the movie oh yeah
she's a famous actress now the actress
that played the daughter
yeah oh right was it mina safari i
haven't heard that name in seoul i know
right
90s or maybe it was i don't know
but yeah okay so let me show you guys a
picture of these two
uh there's mama and dada which
which one's the mom this is the mom over
here yeah
the daughter's over here she always wore
like scarves oh yeah she looks like an
old lady because the teeth are removed
teeth got taken out i forgot about that
oh poor baby yeah
so i wonder how old she is in this photo
ish do we know don't even twenties
don't even know she hasn't hit the 20s
yet but so eventually
you know gypsy starts growing up and she
starts realizing kind of gaps in her
mom's story
at one point she even saw her own birth
certificate she's like wait i'm not
like 14 years old and how weird would
that be
yeah yeah you're not even knowing your
own age like you just find out you're 50
like imagine right now like you find a
birth certificate it's like you're
52 years old i'd be like damn i look
good
and then her mother believe it wait so
she knew she was like 19 or something
but her birth certificate said 14.
so she looked at her she saw her she
just happened to see her birth
certificate she's like wait a minute i'm
not like 14 15 years old what's this and
then
dede the mom basically said oh it's a
misprint so she had like do you miss
print your birth certificate
oh wait so she she knew she was 19. she
didn't know yet
well i mean like she kind of never knew
how she was getting suspicious she was
getting suspicious
because like at one point like oh um my
mom says i'm allergic to this this isn't
this but she would try it while her
mom's sleeping
and she's like wait but i'm fine you
know or like she
actually can get up and walk she's like
but i can walk just fine so of course as
she's growing older she's like none of
this makes sense
and when you get older you also get
really rebellious so she started to
rebel a little bit more
questioning her mom more so
anyway so her mom talks it up to oh it's
just it's just a it's a misprint
whatever and then she can feel
gypsy kind of starting questioning
exactly
the energy shifts she's like [ __ ]
you're a liar
so one day gypsy convinced her mom to
take her to like a science fiction nerd
convention whatever right
because i mean apparently she's a nerd
and it was easier for her to dress up
because she can be a princess she can
put on the wigs and she loved doing that
you know she wanted to be a princess
they go to this convention and she
manages to slip away from her mom for a
little bit
because she starts talking to this man
right yeah but she starts talking to
this man
and basically one thing leads to another
and they
run off to a hotel room together yeah
there's a whole lot of missing details
on that
uh basically no she just met him there
oh she's talking about basically an
escape attempt she's been wanting to
escape
yeah she's been wanting to escape so
this is like one of her maybe not a lot
of guys really give her attention or
something and she thought maybe a guy
could help her get away or
yeah basically i don't know i mean a guy
was listening to her story like
she's like i don't think i'm actually
sick yeah
yeah so walk dee dee eventually finds
them in a hotel room together and she
basically tells them she finds that
was she tracking the wheelchair so good
maybe she should put attractors doesn't
see how but
basically they she found them in a hotel
room they didn't go very far
like if it's a convention and they like
went down the street or something
she's like did you have you seen a girl
in a wheelchair or that girl looks like
this
so she finds her and then tells him
she's underage look at this birth
certificate that she clearly falsified
you know but you know he doesn't know so
he freaks out
who carries around
um so basically there were multiple um
there was multiple escape attempts
attempts
right and in 2011 she tried again with
the man that she met on the internet
but she was found dede smashed her
computer to bits and threatened her like
i'll smash your fingers if you ever try
to escape from me ever again
and um with a hammer or what you know
what they
wow yeah with a hammer um do you think
that they
got discovered because maybe they were
ordering too much
like food delivery probably something
like that probably
okay where did they order that food from
you asked i wish there was a service
like
i just been thinking about that service
yeah i would order food if i was her
from doordash
doordash connects to you with the
restaurants that you love right now and
right to your door and now you can get
the grocery essentials you need with
doordash too
get drinks snacks and other household
items delivered in under an hour
ordering is easy open the doordash app
choose what you want from where you want
and your items will be left safely
outside your door with a contactless
delivery drop-off setting
with over 300 000 partners in the u.s
puerto rico
canada and australia you can support
your neighborhood go-to's or choose from
your favorite national restaurants like
papas chipotle and the cheesecake
factory
for a limited time our listeners can get
25 off and zero delivery fees on their
orders of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter the code
mood that's 25 off up to a 10 value and
zero delivery fees on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter
code mood don't forget that's code mood
for 25
off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply get your
food
and while you're enjoying that delicious
door josh
food make sure you're on a very
comfortable mattress like
a purple mattress because i own one i've
loved it for many many years and i
highly recommend it and the reason why
the purple
is different from any other mattress is
because they have
the grid which is a stretchy gel
material that's amazingly supportive for
your back
and legs while cushioning your shoulders
neck and hips
i don't know how it does it but it's
really really comfortable
and it also keeps you really cool too so
the grid doesn't trap air and air
circulates and flows
through it so you'll never overheat and
then the grid
bounces back as you move and shift
unlike memory foam which remembers
everything and that's why memory foam
has craters and divots
but uh it's actually really awesome too
because even though you're shifting in
the mattress like
one end of the mattress won't move the
other end like spring mattresses like
you know how
that's annoying as hell with spring
spring mattresses
well the purple doesn't do that and
right now you can try
your purple mattress risk free with
with free shipping and returns financing
is available too
purple is comfort for an uncomfortable
world right now you'll get 10
off any order of 200 or more go to
purple.com bigmood10 and use promo code
bigmood10
that's purple.com bigmood10
promo code 10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more once again
that's purple
dot com slash big move 10 promo code big
mood 10.
terms apply sweet so she tried to run
away twice
she tried to run away twice now somehow
gypsy gets a laptop again and after her
mom goes to sleep she would get on the
internet
and uh she made an account at a
christian singles dating website
and this is where she meets nick godijon
so they start talking they start
developing a relationship
eventually they start planning on how
should we meet in person he's from
wisconsin again she's in missouri
so they come up with this elaborate plan
um
she somehow stole money from her mom and
saved up enough money to
buy him a ticket to get to missouri
and the plan was what was he up to these
like he couldn't get his own way there
i mean he was kind of uh he had like he
had a arrest record for indecent
exposure
he has something great to save her i
love him christian
singles she was desperate yeah i'm
sorry to say but i'm kind of questioning
like what kind of people aren't
christian
i mean it sounds like if you have a
record you want someone to really be
forgiving
well oh yeah or they like they found god
and now they're
they're changed yes the second what they
call it the
new birth yeah whatever reborn again
so he had a history like a indecent
exposure and also he had some mental
illnesses
um maybe dissociative identity disorder
or autism jesus
so he's a winner so he went from one
psychopath to another yeah well
let's that's a harsh term for someone
with the id but
true i don't really know well the idea
dissociative identity disorder is like
um something's really traumatic happened
to you and childhood and
you couldn't handle having your
personality all in one
personality so you split off into
different personalities that's true it's
more of like a
like a protective yeah yeah like her mom
is more of an attack
yeah exactly yeah okay so the plan was
uh gypsy and her mom would go to a movie
theater and nick would just
bump into them and that's how they would
strike up a conversation
and maybe start a relationship and then
eventually you know
dede knows it or didi thinks oh we just
met in at this theater she'll let us be
in a relationship
bless you i'm so scared of spilling that
oh my god you have no idea it's just
oh my god i concentrated all your energy
on it
you gave yourself an aneurysm i think i
imploded
you need to be a born-again christian
the devil's inside you
so eventually they meet in the theater
and gypsy somehow slips away
and she and nick have sex in the
bathroom whoa
accelerated fast yeah that was the first
time yeah she was because that was the
first time they met
yeah in person long dry spell so i don't
blame her
so they have sex in the bathroom that's
how she loses her virginity and then
nick goes home afterwards wait where was
dede this whole time
in the theater watching the you know
like mom i gotta go to the bathroom
really quick and
so she gets up i have an inappropriate
question to ask and if it's not
appropriate i didn't edit it out do you
think she sucked his dick without the
teeth
oh my god
you cut that out i think it's hilarious
keep that [ __ ]
yeah she must give bomb the no denture
adventure
yeah we're keeping this [ __ ] in the
episode for sure it's really bad yeah
i feel bad now yeah she wasn't really
she likes it
she did it she did she wanted to okay
she wasn't toothless because she wanted
to be though true
her mom did that she was playing the
hands she was dealt so
of course after that they start planning
their escape it's like they want to be
together so bad
and for some reason they thought the
only way that you know we can escape
is if you murder my mother so they start
planning
i mean that makes sense yeah they start
planning she felt that trap
exactly so they start planning to murder
dede plus like the only way we know this
detail is one of them wanted
everyone to know that they went and had
sex in the bathroom
you're still trying to justify it they
want to know
my joke yeah so after that encounter
they
realized or they decided that the only
way that gypsy can
escape from dede is to basically murder
her and she convinced nick
to kill her mom
so what happened what eventually
unfolded was
one night when dede went to bed gypsy
got up
and let him in through the back door
handed him a knife
some duct tape and some gloves
and she went to the bathroom she hid in
the bathroom covered her ears so that
she wouldn't hear her mother scream
and then nick went into the bedroom and
stabbed her multiple times in the back
that's brutal yeah after that the two
had sex in gypsy's room
and took four thousand dollars in
council had been keeping the house
mostly from
husbands did he have she had sex after
they
okay now i feel less bad about joking
about her second dick with
no teeth yeah so imagine if your mom did
all that to you though like
i don't know but still to have sex after
a murder
something's a little crazy he's like
yeah the revenge and the vengeance and
the freedom
is just passion but the sex is really
really creepy i'm trying to find out
what i don't know i just want to run
away
i would yeah if you're really like
trying to if you're really trying to
escape
your captor i don't think the very next
thing on your mind is sex that's a
little
maybe she's like ding dong the witch is
dead let me reward you yeah
yeah so take that money that's what he
wanted
maybe like in exchange for this i'll
give you this yeah he was really into
like bdsm and all that oh that makes
sense
yeah she went from one abuser to another
great yikes
so she well he didn't really abuse her
you know but he's just like well it
sounds like manipulat
like like maybe he helps kind of the the
sickness part of it because like they're
murdering her and then [ __ ] and that
sounds very sick
yeah she was the one that convinced him
like you know
help me murder my mother as we get out
they were just like blindly in love and
just crazy
so they have sex and then they run off
with their money
they leave the house and they book
tickets like train tickets or whatever
or greyhound tickets
to go to uh his home where he lives with
his parents in wisconsin
they pack up the murder weapon they ship
it to his house
because they figure that's you know
that's how they're gonna hide it which
is actually
kind of a good idea i think i mean
getting it really really far away
not a terrible idea yeah and
gypsy is still logged into a shared
facebook account that she has with her
mother on her phone
and she wanted the body to be found oh
so she posted on
so fast and so she posted on
the facebook the [ __ ] is finally dead
what yeah how would she be why did she
give it away she just admitted to it
not the part is so people on facebook of
course are now concerned
and they were like wait she doesn't
really speak like this like
what's going on so people start calling
didi no phone call they go to the house
no ants or anything um they see that the
car is still there so they didn't take
any like medical trips or anything
anywhere so the car is still there
and then eventually the neighbors call
the cops to do a welfare check
so the cops are on the body and then one
of the neighbors comes over and she's
like this 23 year old girl
or woman who's who told the cops you
know
gypsy actually mentioned to me in the
past that she met a guy online but i
didn't really think much of it
um maybe you want to look into this so
they
traced the ip of where that facebook
status was posted and it led to his
house
yeah and that's eventually how they
found the couple there
and that's how they got arrested so uh
now gypsy is serving 10 years in prison
and she has
uh she can be up for parole in 2024
and he is serving life in prison wow
and then people are just basically like
that sucks because she had any other
choices she should get
um whatever her sentence was minus what
her mom's sentence would have been
had her mom gotten oh yeah yeah then
it's like
no but that's not how our justice system
works nikki
i know but i'm saying be more fair
we can't be the one to swing the
what is it the freaking travels the oh
sorry that was
that stark okay if i was giving out
sentences
i must swing the sword everyone watching
it again that's why
exactly three again that's why it's
funny so this is what gypsy
and uh nick look like these are their
their
prison photos here give me your tray she
looks
a lot better there i guess her hair grew
out and so that's what they look like
um and people are basically like oh
that's kind of shitty i mean yeah she
did plot the murder
but jesus given the circumstances like
what would you do because at one point
her mother even
told the police that oh yeah my
daughter's mentally
you know like she's basically kidnapped
yeah yeah and tortured her entirely
i mean there are other options right if
she was able to
meet up with the sky travel do all this
[ __ ] she could have also just
cops and i mean not even call the cops
no just you could just
take greyhound to la say look i just
left
my mom in michigan i need help she was
holding me captive
she was hurting me obviously there's
like built up resentment and
i need to start over and i need help
yeah not just that but then imagine
from birth all the way up until your 20s
you're being tortured by your mom and
i'm pretty sure
well she's getting praised right
everything but then also like all these
years
i'm pretty sure her mom instilled a [ __ ]
ton of fear in her and that's why she
didn't leave and that's why she had to
plan
this she didn't seem very fearful
because she just met up with a dude
[ __ ] him they killed her and then they
[ __ ] in the house again
it's like but then if she was fearful
then why not leave
she's in a different way the reason why
is because she was
convinced her mom convinced her that no
one would help you because
one she signed over the papers that said
she was mentally you know not there
so she's afraid that if she were to go
to anyone they'll just be like oh yeah
you know we saw this your mom said that
you're not so you don't know what you're
talking about
she also um dede actually went to the
cops and said you know my daughter's
um she has a mind like the mental
capacity of a seven-year-old
so she now gypsy is also convinced that
the cops wouldn't help her either
yeah that makes sense because she hasn't
had a chance to like try to get help and
murder is the only way out otherwise
your mom's gonna find you and legally
you have to be
right with her yeah and her mom was such
a great liar
you know people would ask her like
where's all the medical records when she
was a kid like oh hurricane katrina
destroyed it oh
she had a life she was always probably
in her head thinking of the next
right i'm gonna have to tell very
manipulative and
sneaky yeah i mean for me it's easy to
be like well just
you know go and ask for help like go
farther away where
her mom doesn't have a manipulative
control around the community
and just say like look this is what's
happening um i
she has a computer i looked it up i
think this is my channel it's a healthy
mind you're able to do that
but after 20 years of torture i don't
know and being beat down and
feeling like you have no way out at all
and then this guy
is crazy enough to yeah get you out of
there
yeah we're so in love she he's willing
to do anything yeah i mean from
you can't get a healthy thinking mind
from such a
toxic you know abusive situation yeah
when all you've ever known is like
you're stuck in a cage or stuck in a
cage forever like yeah she has the kids
attack
everybody's agreed that she's like
allowed to have this key
yeah that's true uh so
according to interviews and stuff people
are saying and and
and gypsy's caseworker says that she's
actually thriving in prison
because now she has the freedom to you
know learn things in prison she does
photography
she gets to eat whatever is in prison
like she's imagine being such a caged
bird that
prison yeah that's so true
and like you know she can finally be an
adult and when asked now
she is not happy that her mother is dead
you know she
of course not yeah she probably didn't
want to yeah she probably would rather
have them built a relationship and
her mom not be crazy yeah and all the
neighbors are just basically like
shocked because dede
was so good as at acting as this devoted
mother
except angel worse i wonder if anyone
like really
that's a horrible thing to say i'm not
going to say it the most upsetting thing
about it is that there were doctors who
had an inkling but they never reported
it like they just
that's true she was a nurse so she knew
how to like
say the right things or just to leave
and they're so busy that maybe they
you know it's easy just to be like well
the mom seems a little weird but
whatever they're not in my office
they're not my face out of sign
i don't mind but i think what helps now
is i i don't know if this is everywhere
but i feel like
a lot of the um doctors offices that
i've been to they're all part of a
network now so there's like
if i go to a hospital like in this city
it's actually connected
it's in the same network as this one and
there's all of my information is online
so
even stuff out of network i've had
doctors like populate
information into this system now from
like 10 doctors ago and i'm like oh [ __ ]
they have all of my information
now all in one website so i feel like as
time goes by maybe it would be harder to
just yeah
run from different doctors and like be
hiding diagnoses and stuff so maybe
that's a small piece of like the kind of
big brother
thing that could potentially help save
some people who might be going through
this munchausen's thing or like
faking illnesses or because your whole
records will kind of start to be more
connected in this system
so this actually all took place uh where
my parents live now and it's literally
um the house that she was murdered in is
10 minutes away from my parents house so
of course i went so excited
you took pictures oh yeah this is the
house it's actually a really cute house
did you go in there no oh my god it has
it has the wheelchair access
the wheelchair oh my god wow telling
people like
hey like leave us the [ __ ] alone yeah so
people live there i have no idea i
didn't see anyone in there they have a
sign where it says like keep
out but you're still like click
so of course i made my mom take me there
and it was it was really cool because at
that point i was just i was watching the
show on netflix too i was like oh [ __ ]
there's the ramp the show has pushed her
up in
wow all right really quick we want to
interrupt and give a shout out to our
sponsor
candid are you unhappy with your smile
you don't have to be
thousands of people have used candid
like a nicky smile
i'm pretty unhappy with your smile right
now nikki uh
candid has clear comfortable removable
practically invisible aligners to help
straighten your teeth
and now if he's candid you will love
your smile here we go nikki loves her
smile i love your smile candy's here to
help straighten your teeth so you can
fall
in love with your smile your treatment
is prescribed and closely monitored
remotely by a licensed orthodontist
a real orthodontist guys who's an expert
in tooth movement
you have the same quality of care you
get from an in-office orthodontist from
the comfort and convenience of your own
home
while other companies use general
dentists candid only works with
orthodontist
the same orthodontist who created your
plan is with you from start to finish so
you never have to wonder how you're
actually doing
the average candid treatment is just six
months and you'll start seeing results
way before then it costs thousands less
than traditional braces
become your best you started start
straightening your teeth today right now
you can save
seventy five dollars on candid starter
kit
go to candidco.com mood and use our code
mood to let them know we sent you that's
candidco.com
mood and use code mood take advantage of
this limited time offer to save
75 on your starter kit that's candid
co.com
mood and use code mood yeah and if you
were trying to get healthy
for the new year but then like maybe
valentine's day messed you up a little
bit
and you know being at home valentine's
day listen well it messed me up a lot i
ate a lot of candy alone i was very sexy
see maybe you should try noom because
noom is based in science
but built by psychologists noom doesn't
give you rules but instead teaches you
how to think
so you can accomplish your personal
health health goals stick with them long
term and get healthy for good
so specific goals you want to achieve um
they can help you like with the physical
aspect of it eating better to feel
better
and have more energy rather than just
like focusing on calories the
psychological aspect like an improved
sense of self-worth instead of sometimes
like if you recognize that you're eating
to fill a void
in you you maybe address that
psychological aspect instead of
um continuing to like just try to force
yourself to eat better
uh or sometimes uh social there's social
aspects you feel like you always need to
drink in your hand
if you're gonna be talking to people or
you need to be snacking on something
because you're
just calming your anxieties those are
all like things that you need to address
psychologically and nume helps you to do
that
it's just 10 minutes a day the tone of
the program works with your lifestyle
and you don't have to commit to a
rigorous plan
i like that it teaches you why you make
the choices you do and gives you the
tools to replace your habits with
healthier ones
using cognitive behavioral approaches
and all kinds of fancy
schmancy psychological terms like that
there's a science to getting healthier
it's called new
sign up for your trial today at
noomnom.com
big mood learn how to get healthy with
noom sign up for your trial today at
noom
noom.com big mood ready to learn how to
live healthier sign up for new
today at noom.com
big mood awesome okay
i have a little bit more information all
right so obviously the neighbors were
like oh my god how can this be she was
so sweet she was
obviously she was sick i mean look at
her the mother is this angel of a woman
however
dede's family wanted [ __ ] all to do with
it they
were so happy that she was dead wow what
they were happy she was dead
well the mom was like yeah she almost
killed me
mom did die because you know from heaven
she was like yeah right
she tried killing me hello she killed me
because she was stealing things from
them
she was writing uh you know bad checks
bad checks and she was
they you know they had an idea that she
was
poisoning her mother um so
her family is happy that she's dead her
dad her stepmom her cousin when
they found out she was dead nobody wants
to go pick up her ashes yeah that's
actually the thing that i was gonna say
that i was like maybe no that's horrible
i shouldn't say it i was actually gonna
ask like
did did anyone even mourn for her they
probably knew that this was happening
to gypsy and there's nothing that they
could do about it geez go to the cops
she signed a waiver like this is before
but when they did bring it up to dede
just simply packed up and left yeah she
would just keep probably just keep
running mission
of guilt by silence when did this happen
like 90s ish
2000s this was 2000 the murder happened
in 2000 because it was after katrina so
it wasn't 15 ago 2015.
yeah so eventually someone did pick up
one you know a family member did pick up
her ashes and they flushed it down the
toilet oh
yeah how they felt about her did they
say who
who it was like they said i believe it
was
then where is it where is it where is it
i mean if your whole family
feels their father and stepmother that
strongly
they i feel like they should have done
more
yeah honestly save gypsy do you know if
gypsy has any sort of relationship with
her family
no that they don't say anything about
that damn
yeah i wonder i wish that they tried to
reach out afterwards yeah
um but you know people in prison or the
people there said that
instead of losing weight and just like
being miserable like how everyone is
when they go to prison she's like
gaining weight
and she's looking good this is what she
looks like in prison actually she got a
glow up in prison
she got hair now oh wow that's cute
oh i thought that i thought her shirt
was like i used to have a shirt like
that in high school
but it's actually a prison shirt it was
an outfit yeah you look like a prisoner
in high school high school is a prison
damn that's crazy man i mean yeah if
if your own family is happy that you
are dead then god damn you're a horrible
person when you're alive
right geez like what kind of i don't
know definitely she had some sort of
oh wait is this a is it like a mental
disorder the thing you guys can
yeah how do you spell that munchausen by
approximately
well munch houses i guess on its own
that's like probably the name of the
doctor or something
that figured out oh munch house okay
syndrome and then so munchausen
is like is there do you have the actual
definition is that we're just like you
personally are faking
illness for attention
syndrome is when someone tries to get
attention sympathy by falsifying
inducing
and or exaggerating an illness okay yeah
they lie about symptoms
so sometimes i wonder um
because you know how the hypochondrias
thing so sometimes like i
get nervous that like does my
hypochondria mix in with munchausen
sometimes because i'm like do i just
want attention for feeling sick but then
i'm like no no
yeah you're not asking for attention
yeah it's just i literally have a fear
yeah because i cuz i struggle with that
too all the time and i have to like
continuously counter argue like why i
don't have it
and like do a lot of research because
i'm convinced like i have ms or like i'm
going to have an ms diagnosis at some
point oh my goodness
but like i don't have any evidence of
that
but i just like i'll have like symptoms
that fall in line with it but then i'm
like
literally all the blood tests i've ever
had have come back normal i don't know
if it can actually be
found through a blood test but so
sometimes like late at night when i have
i'll have a lot of symptoms but the
anxiety symptoms i think sometimes
they can make it mirror that right but
then i'm like do i
like why do i is that some sort of weird
thing like other than hypocrites
when you're thinking about ghosts in
your house and then every little sound
yeah it feels like it goes you start
convincing yourself
but so i guess the munch houses is
actually really like like
really drastically like making yourself
sick and stuff like that
okay sabotaging tests so it's kind of
[ __ ] up though that if you have that
inclination though that you would put it
on someone else and especially a child
yeah that's really weird yeah like do it
to yourself
you're getting attention for being so
great
and you're sacrificing yourself for this
person
it's far worse to do it part by proxy
than to do it on youtube
affecting their life yeah is that the
same thing where
there's like those nurses that end up
making their patients sick just oh yeah
that's the same thing by proxy yeah so
can you imagine like the
uh then when the news broke that um you
know
people at first were were concerned
because
didi was found dead where's her daughter
so now they're thinking this poor
handicapped girl got
kidnapped and like they don't like she
doesn't have her medication she's gonna
die
and then the news comes out that it's
her own daughter that
plotted all this i think i remember this
case now it's starting to come back to
me because it wasn't that long ago it
was pretty famous
yeah we reported on jk news yeah um
so i totally forgot all the details yeah
i don't know i for some reason i can't
really let go of like i'm still upset
with the daughter though like even
though she was a victim
um and and i understand like how she was
led to
murder i'm still angry about it for some
reason
like i still like well i think it's like
sex
parts it's probably the sex part
now i don't feel like you're that
desperate that yeah like
i don't know there's something about
release you know like you're holding
you're so scared you're so scared you're
so scared and now it's like a release
like you're just like free
like i don't know i i feel like people
express themselves in different ways
and the sex part isn't a deterrent for
me
on like here just adds another level
where i'm like
what's going on i think it's weird as
like she was never able to develop
relationships properly so yeah it didn't
feel
inappropriate for her maybe and she's
like oh this guy that i'm in love with
totally just murdered someone for me
like this is love
like we're still like yeah feels like
like has feelings for him
not just like sexual deviant you know
and she's 19
peak hormones and you feel like this guy
just
rescued you like this guy saved your
life now you're allowed to have a
regular life like you
i don't know i i don't but i feel like a
good little 24 hours
after murdering your mom maybe because
you're a healthy person
like you know part of me wonders like if
her mom had the genetic disposition
for some sort of mental illness like
does she have one too and so maybe if it
is mental illness then i could give her
more of a pass but obviously we don't
have a diagnosis to go on i'm just kind
of like wow you murdered her and then
you [ __ ] in front of
you know in front of her dead body like
great like i'm starting to feel less
sad for her but i guess that's just my
own bias two decades of
being tortured and used as this like
person's dummy to get
attention and like robbed of your whole
life you
like you got your teeth pulled out like
she took everything
that's true and then and you think it's
gonna last forever like you're trapped
forever you don't
see an end of the tunnel for this and
then all of a sudden this guy
saves you from it i don't know i if i
really try to put myself
in their shoes which i'll never be able
to yeah i i feel like
i would feel free like i would feel like
holy [ __ ] because i've had less because
i've never been less severe
i've never been trapped instances where
yeah like i felt like oh my god this is
never gonna end and i'm i'm trapped
forever and
then when i got free i was like wow like
i don't give a [ __ ] if that person died
because
um they were so cruel like like so cruel
that i i i can't i have a hard time
um that's true yeah i guess if i've
never really felt trapped at all in fact
i felt more abandoned than trapped
so understanding a relief i wouldn't
being trapped
it's hard for me to yeah i know you
wouldn't do the same thing but
i i guess yeah maybe that's what it is
is like i can't yeah you've been
parallel in my own life at all i can't
imagine like
that amount of torture and pain for
years
from someone that's supposed to be
taking care of you and loving you yeah
yeah no after prison because i mean it's
coming up pretty soon
yeah she's coming out she's uh qualified
for parole but
do you do you guys think that she'll
actually visit the dude and still try to
keep him in her life
i don't think he's i mean he's i don't
know
yeah yeah after she's out he's gonna
deliberate
yeah well i feel like they're kind of
bonded right because he
was like that big major turning point so
i wouldn't be surprised but like
you never know what kind of mental like
growth she's had since she's been
there she might be like well this is
[ __ ] up i need to go in a different
way
yeah i am really curious to see what
would happen once she gets out how is
she going to live
right now she should go to is she yeah
she has no like she's she never
had any learning or independence or
anything but maybe that's a good
stepping stone like
prison usually is a [ __ ] hell for
people but
from coming from hell that could have
offered some stability
and for her to actually probably one of
the only times where prison was actually
rehabilitated for so
true she got autonomy back for her own
body
yeah imagine never having control of
your own body or person always having to
be sick like her mom would always make
her sick so she could never just
probably just read a book or like learn
things so she's doing photography in
prison they said that she's doing
photography she's doing all kinds of
things it just makes her so happy that
she can actually
like autonomy she has her yeah yeah yeah
i can't imagine being robbed of that for
that many
for the two decades poor girl that's
crazy
is it worth murder i don't i can't say
that um i don't
think i would ever go there but you know
i don't know i've never lived in her
shoes so
exactly yeah it is kind of like when you
get to that murder
passion thing it's like the mom is
supposed to be the number one protector
yeah so in a way it feels morally like
vindicated i guess
to like she deserves to die because yeah
of that so i wasn't remorseful at all
yeah literally no one was sad about it
no that's insane but it's also [ __ ] up
how they weren't even
there to help her either yeah like well
the thing is deedee kept on changing her
name
over and over so it's hard for them to
attract it'd be hard to find her
that makes sense yeah has any of their
family members commented since
um i uh gypsy's dad actually was
not as angry as the family
he said where is it
that's his ex his ex-wife yeah um he
said
i think dede's problem was that she
started to web allies and there was just
no escaping after
it was like a tornado that got started
um so he doesn't see her as a
morally evil person he just sees her as
like oh this little thing spun out of
control
and he was happy the first time that he
saw a video of gypsy walking under her
own power
hmm poor guy like he was lied to the
whole time and then
on some on some occasions where he was
allowed to talk on the phone
with gypsy uh dede would tell him like
oh you know
gypsy thinks she's only 14 years old so
make sure you don't say anything else
you know because she's not mentally
capable of you know understanding how
old she is so just
stick to the story that she's 14 years
old wow
this woman was an incredible liar for
sure yeah
and it was crazy because my my mom
actually remembered when all this
happened too really
it happened you know all while she was
living there yeah i guess if she's
living in the same town
yeah that's that's breaking news yeah
for a little missouri town
a little more town not that long ago too
yeah
yeah i am i sympathize with her
did the dad ever have like other kids
oh it doesn't say he did remarry yeah
how did uh how did the dude's family
feel
no nothing around there too not that
i've seen but i don't think people
really
it was more about like gypsy and her her
mother okay
yeah that's a bigger part of the story
yeah i wonder how common this munchausen
by proxy and i wonder if it's genetic or
if it's
i've never really done it like what's
the cure
therapy take the person away
it's crazy that she started this at only
three months old
that's the saddest thing like she's been
about this level i mean like even before
that she was poisoning her own mother
this [ __ ] has been crazy
yeah yeah so munchausen's by proxy
when you look at what the cause is
there's actually not
really any causes at all they don't they
aren't sure
you're crazy [ __ ] but people are saying
it's probably linked to
their scissors childhood so that makes
sense a lot of things are linked to
their childhood
it sounds very narcissistic like you
want to be
praised and and celebrated another
yeah you don't care you don't have any
empathy towards what you're doing to
another person's life
as long as it makes you look good um but
as an update
now recently it turns out that gypsy
rose is engaged
to a man that she was a pen pal with in
prison
oh that's interesting so she's moved on
from her boyfriend
unfortunately the other dude nick the
murderer um
when asked about the you know the days
after murdering
her mother and you know spending time
with gypsy he said quote
that was man probably the best days of
my life that's the only way i can
describe it i enjoyed every second of it
from the very beginning i just knew we
were soul mates those five days when i
was actually with her
physically with her those five days only
five days
[Applause]
after the murder yeah yeah um those five
days
were the most intense and magical and
awe-inspiring days i've ever had
wow yeah poor dude he's still living in
a fantasy
yeah his plan was i was gonna get a job
and start looking for an apartment after
a little ways down the road i'd probably
end up marrying her and end up having
children with her
that's something i've never had with
anyone else to this day she's the only
one i've ever
had that with well i'm a little glad
they didn't end up having children
together oh yeah
right it was built off of a interesting
situation
yeah that's crazy and when asked about
how he felt about killing dede he said
sometime or somehow i just knew
deep within my heart some way me and her
would end up being together in the end
there's no other option we gotta do it i
wanted to make sure her mom was not
gonna harm anyone anymore
and i made sure of that man he like he
basically threw
his life away for her and he's like
still hanging on to those like five days
like there was some sort of dream
and you know she's moved on from it yeah
do we know how long they were
talking before they met up so uh they
were
before they met up i'm not sure but then
after that
movie theater the sex and movie theater
thing theater thing
they talked online for another year and
that's when they met up again a year
later and killed her
and it was said that during that year of
communication on the internet and stuff
it was a lot of like sexting and he was
like really into roleplay of bdsm and
all that and
it was a very like highly sexually
driven thing maybe that's why when they
met up they were finally able to release
that sexual intention
that makes sense if they were like
online buddies the whole time
yeah yeah they couldn't wait until they
left the house they were like
after murdering her i wonder if they
talked about that like no
no you know it was crazy i actually when
this first came out
i actually looked up the mom's facebook
and i saw the actual post
that said it was still there it was
still there facebook didn't take this
[ __ ] it was like really early on in the
case when the news broke and everything
they got curious
yeah so it was kind of surreal to see it
looks creepy like that
and then the comments from the friends
and stuff like oh my god dede is
everything okay what's going on and then
the
friends were like does anyone know
what's going on yeah we called her like
you can see
all the conversations of all the friends
yeah it was wild actually
maybe i wonder if i should look at it
yeah and back then facebook was like the
number one
oh yeah 2015. yeah yeah yeah yeah moved
on a little bit
but but still like we're still going up
there
there's so many facebook profiles of
people that have moved on and it's
no it's still here weird everything's
just oh yeah that [ __ ] is dead
yeah whoa post is still there oh yeah
the profile's still there oh my god
but that post like they take down all
kinds of [ __ ]
facebook and they didn't take that one
i'm surprised so they shared an account
it's called djib
blanchard so maybe they shared an
account so there's 165 comments let me
see if i can scroll
so it says the [ __ ] is dead and people
are saying what's going on
did your facebook get hacked um d
what's wrong this is not d she doesn't
talk like this someone notified the
local police
uh please report it somebody said uh we
live down the road from them we are
headed there now
and then it's just a lot of people
saying please update please update any
news we're so worried
call the police with the address what
kind of heartless person would post them
like that
about anyone especially these two um
police have been called police are here
no news yet
please any info i am here the police are
trying to find her
is her nissan cube there yes the car is
here there they are not we're trying to
cover all bases no news
so all the neighbors are there and
they're updating it here and then
you can trace the ip address oh please
dear god make sure they're okay
um somebody here says it's not official
but
my friends uh gypsy blanchard is missing
i might be jumping down but god forbid
something happened then please share
okay yeah that's crazy how it's just
like they're there like a moment frozen
in time
exactly it's almost like it's like
crazy that it's real because like it
feels
feels like a museum yeah right like a
fairy tale story that's not very
it's weird that the facebook pages don't
go anywhere like after people
die so the final
no so the final post and people just
stopped commenting afterwards
uh the final post was a link to an
article that says
sheriff said she can walk daughter and
murder case suspected of fraud
dang it feels weird like that it's
public that we're kind of like
invading their privacy in a way yeah
that's not like
it's like real and it's like right there
yeah it's like i'm tampering with
evidence
yeah yeah a lot of people thought that
they were missing because
you know once the cops got there
obviously you can't just break in they
had to wait
for a warrant and so that's why a lot of
people on the facebook are like what's
going on they're missing they're missing
they're missing
because nobody was answering and then
eventually it turns out you know once
they got the more the cops went in there
and found the body
jeez imagine being a neighbor a
concerned neighbor out there like oh my
gosh where are they and then finding
find out like [ __ ] her body was in there
the whole time yeah
and then having to hear the news that
yeah about all the details
right like what this girl endured right
underneath your nose yeah
it's crazy so that is the story of gypsy
rose blanchard and dede blanchard
the story of a woman who just seemed
like the sweetest angel in the whole
entire world was really evil
and i do feel for for gypsy like snow
white's mom
or is it her mom that means that yeah
well thanks for watching today's episode
y'all we are sauced
so this green drink and make one they're
good
they are really good i hope you guys
liked that episode uh
and if you guys did i mean i'm sure you
did because why else would you be here
make sure you guys
like the video give us five stars on
itunes and everywhere else
and subscribe subscribe to us and we'll
see you guys next time bye
i love you say it back